okay right we are now live uh welcome to
this meeting of uh cabinet
and uh i would actually like before we
formally convinced to welcome
councillor andrew crump
to his
first meeting of canada in his new role
and doubtless the jokes won't improve
i apologize for absence we've got
apologies from councillor cargill
thank you
uh disclosures of interest any
disclosures of interest
okay
thank you
councillor harvey
uh
in that case moving on item three
minutes
uh is everyone happy with the minutes of
the meetings held on the 11th of april
and 11th of may
right in that case i will sign the
minutes at the close of the meeting
so moving swiftly on
item 4
adoption of the even dacid parish plan
councillor pemberton
thank you um chair and leader um
members this item um
is around the avon dassett
parish plan
whereby
we are now at the stage where having had
a
car a consultation exercise
with
93 households
i thought i'd switch that off
93 households uh responding uh being
consulted rather in 78 households
responding which is an 84 return rate we
are in the position where uh the a
vendasic parish plan which is at
appendix one
can and should be adopted as a material
consideration in determining planning
applications in accordance with the
current
course strategy and as such is
considered to be an important source of
local information
thank you councillor pemberton thank you
are there any comments or observations
from members of cabinet
councillor harvey that
two things to mention uh one is i think
whoever this group was that put together
this parish plan should be commended for
the speed of their progress now even
does it may be a relatively small
settlement but nevertheless the amount
of work that is involved is considerable
and so i'd like to offer my
congratulations to them and in that vein
my one question is
um is it
possible is it norm is that acceptable
to record the names in the plan of those
who formed that that committee done the
donkey work because
i think they deserve a bit of public
recognition
very good points there councillor harvey
councillor pemberton thank you i'm not
sure whether there is anything to
preclude naming the members of of groups
i'll take that away with officers
and uh before we came to the
recommendations
um
brand new phone i can't work out
yeah i'm gonna take it outside
brand new phone about for two days i
can't switch it off um uh you did beat
me to the punch counselor harvey when we
came to the vote of the recommendation i
was indeed also going to uh record
thanks on behalf of uh officers for the
work that's been done on behalf of the
council
so having dealt with that question i'm
now going to throw my phone in a bucket
of water
thank you councillor pemberton
councillor felin i see you indicated you
wish to speak
as the ward member i would like to thank
the hard work
done by
sarah brook taylor trying to call a tim
brook taylor as i did before
um
and various members of the parish
council
[Music]
including um sarah
richardson
and the
chair of the parish council
trevor gill they've done work very hard
to get it done as
councillor javier said and also the
district council
[Music]
officers who were involved in it
thank you
so i see no one else wishing to comment
so the recommendation on page 13
i assume you are proposing that
council of pemberton
can and councillor jennings ii did
uh is everyone in favor of the
recommendation on page 13.
thank you members of cabinets moving on
uh
item five custom and self-guild tusk and
finish group councillor pemberton again
thank you chair
members um what is before you um are the
results of the recently
um
set up
member task and finish group
to look at
how we best
manage and give life to government
policy around custom and self-build uh
in relation to the specific needs of our
own communities and and this particular
district's housing market
first of all
i will commend uh councillor rock and
the members of the task and finish group
for a thorough piece of work that has
been concluded um much like the
avondacit
parish plan um with pace
um it is important for
our communities
decision makers and those who wish to
secure self-built or custom properties
that there is as much clarity
as early as possible in our handling and
management of this
type of development
don't shout so much is that better
so it was my fault
so
um
before you is the task and finish report
and what has been recommended is that
we accept the report and that as the
portfolio holder um i'd be tasked with
reviewing considering the
recommendations and bringing forward in
conjunction with officers
a revised policy
that will
in its first iteration find life within
the site allocations plan
before i go any further and before i
bring uh
john carefort the head of the policy
team
into this or uh and and his and his
colleagues matthew neil and paul harris
um i understand that uh that we have at
least one speaker on the matter i think
that's liz nicholson
formerly of the planning development
parish of stratfor district council a
long time ago um perhaps we should think
about uh we should hear what she's got
to say first next i would agree
councillor pemberton
would you care to come up to a
microphone and address the meeting
please
and
i've just been reminded that formally
you have three minutes
thank you
sorry i need my glasses these days and i
forget that bit um
your officers will be aware that two
non-determination appeals have been
submitted on behalf of roscon strategic
land in respect of their self and custom
build sites in welford and long
itchington
i'm aware that cabinet considers matters
of policy it's not a committee meeting
for the individual planning applications
i just wanted to say that everything i
say today is the same as the policy
matters that we've raised in those
appeal submissions that we've already
made
so whilst we support the need for a
reasonable marketing period so that
legitimate concerns raised by local
communities can be addressed roscon has
previously identified a number of
examples to your officers of recently
adopted policies in kettering corby and
wellingborough that provide for a
marketing period of six months and
central bedfordshire which proposes 12
months and all of these were considered
to be reasonable and justified by
independence inspectors
as reported to your overview and
scrutiny committee on the 29th of april
your task and finish group found that
oxford city basing stoke and dean
chelmsford city and forrester dean all
use a 12-month marketing period
bedford borough uses 12 months for sites
of 50 or more dwellings and 6 months for
smaller sites
it also confirms that there was no
evidence of marketing periods for longer
than 12 months
and goes on to refer to representations
made by the house homebuilders
federation to the chukesbury borough
plan where it was argued that the
proposed 12-month period in that plan
should be shortened to six months
whilst your osc report refers to
discussions with the right to build task
force which indicated a marketing period
between 12 and 24 months would be
appropriate
this was dependent upon the size of the
site and available plots
the report does not provide any reason
justification for choosing a 24-month
period and this time period clearly
conflicts with all of the evidence from
the other local authorities none of
which use a period of more than 12
months and many of which use six months
you all know that a decision maker in
planning whether that's on individual
applications or in preparing policies
must have evidence-based reasons for
making their decisions
there is no evidence to support a
proposed time period of 24 months for
marketing and a decision of this could
be deemed irrational
roscon had proposed and reached
agreement with your officers last year
that a nine-month period of marketing is
both evidence-based and reasonable
and it's clearly consistent with the
task and finish groups research which
concluded that the council's current
strategy of nine-month marketing period
falls in the middle of marketing
strategies currently being used by other
authorities
we therefore ask that the cabinet
support a marketing period that's
consistent with the evidence that you
have before you as opposed to a period
that's neither credible nor justified
thank you
are there any questions for liz
nicholson
i'll take that as a no thank you
uh
councillor rock do you want to uh make
any comments at this point
uh thank you chairman and good afternoon
and uh
thank you for letting me drop in um i i
thought i'd just come and observe
because um it's a sort of slight replay
of what we did at the osc so uh i'm just
happy to answer any questions that i'm
able
and uh the portfolio holder myself had a
series of conversations
and subsequent to the osce meeting and i
i'm confident
that uh he's in possession of all the
facts and can deal with any matters that
might arise but if i'm happy to answer
any questions that might arise if i can
assist thank you
thank you councillor rob although
if i want to express
thanks to
everybody that was involved in this
including the officers and the members
of the committee
thank you again councillor rock
councillor parry
thank you leader um
i'm aware of having received some
correspondence from um an outside
um
planning
uh expert
um
and he did raise the question about uh
the richard bacon review that was
commissioned by the prime minister last
year i just wondered um if osc could
make some references perhaps to why
or or had they looked at it or was
probably a very valid reason because
it's a very high level governmental type
of review that it wasn't mentioned
uh or taken into account during this
particular task and finished group
thank you
new councillor parry and i think
everyone's had a copy of this letter in
front of them for this meeting
it's a very valid question councillor
parry uh
do you wish to pick this up councillor
pemberton i think possibly if one if
john or one of his team could just pick
up um
i i'd rather not sort of steal the
thunder of the task and finish group
itself i i have an understanding of why
it wasn't uh specifically considered but
perhaps john if you want to pick that up
mr
careful thank you
um yes i mean the group could have
acknowledged um its its existence but
fundamentally for the reasons you've
given the councillor it's a very high
level uh report and doesn't actually um
affect you know what we're we're doing
here we're trying to implement
government policy that review was
setting government policy so yeah in
that sense it wasn't directly relevant
since the
lack of reference to it
that's fine thank you very much
thank you
so are there any other comments
junit
i just wonder whether i could refer to
something um is
that came at the tuscan fish group which
which is really part of the site
allocations plan
what uh when the site allocations plan
looks at custom-built and self-build i
think do they take into account um the
housing situation the affordable housing
situation in any particular
community
because i do know that there was one
self-built custom-built self-built
site in ulster
which has got green belt around it
which has got a real problem with the
provision of affordable housing and the
the inability to find other sites is
that something that is weighed up or
will um you know perhaps we can
it refers to the task and finish group
but it's actually more of a site
allocations plan
and maybe that's where that could be
answered perhaps better than uh here
do you want to respond to that
councillor pemberton thank thank you
chair um i i'll defer to john for the
technical answer around the obligations
on developers for affordable housing
on self-built and custom-built sites
um
the
the the this particular policy is is is
um
part of
the site allocations plan but it's it's
being as an add-on if you will i think
the question around site-specific
matters are really more for
individual development management
proposals
um
and clearly as we get to
a new plan um which we we we've already
embarked upon that process um
there will be a further iteration of the
custom and self-build policy
in the same way that we have we have a
as in essence an interim policy around
climate change climate change spd as
you'll recall councillor juned um
so i i doubt that this particular
particularly given the speed of the
review
would absolutely pick up every
individual nuance
and nor would i as a sort of as the
portfolio holder be keen
uh
to delay
um the site allocations plan
consultation process
i think there are probably other ways of
doing it but perhaps if john would like
just to for the benefit of members of
cabinet to uh just outline some of the
uh the
the the duties around uh self-building
custom-built thank you
yes thank you
am i right thinking counsellor that this
is a site that has been promoted as a
affordable housing exception site but is
now being promoted as custom self-filled
and that's the the concern the loss of
the union
it was originally um
affordable it's been in a site as as a
custom-built self-build um
previously um and it still it still is
in the site allocations plan the
question really is is there a balance uh
judgment taken when you've got a
community that's got very very little
other land is and there is a shortage of
affordable is that part of the judgment
that is taken as to whether this should
be site uh this particular site should
be uh custom built and self-built or
whether affordable housing takes the um
the higher um priority if you like in
the site allocations plan
yes that's a fair fair comment a fair
observation and one that
um is has been made before really about
the operation of the core strategy and
whether it's delivering affordable homes
in the places that perhaps most need
them and i think there's a there is a
case in austria where there's a
relatively high full browsing need and
not too much uh general housing coming
forward although we've got the sites
that alimore lane that are that are
underway um not specifically is the the
short answer to it and as always
planning as a balance we've got
um a choice between a rural exception
site here for the housing scheme versus
the need to find sites for customer self
build the fact that being i think
promoted for custom and self build now
would suggest that although a affordable
housing scheme would be desirable it's
not one that perhaps would be
deliverable because i thought the
landowner is now looking for so it's
unfortunate when you do have situations
where you're you're choosing
uh the optimum use of sites
uh in this case yeah we can't have both
um but we we haven't taken that direct
comparison i think it's really one for
the new plan about how we better match
delivery of affordable housing with the
with the needs across the district
thank you thank you uh mr careford
councillor crump and councillor harvey
then council of fielding
thank you mr chairman um yeah this i
welcome this this report
um
been on planning committee um when it
the welfare demand one came for the
south field uh i think it was nine
houses and i'm sure the chair will
correct me if it wasn't on um
this there was a lot of uncertainty
around the application and it was
debated in detail and uh
the officers were debated with uh
questioned and i know mr harris
was interrogated by me uh
for quite a bit
so i think this tuscan finish group on
customer self build is trying to give
members more insert and more certainty
regarding the planning process
and i think this has gone a long way
towards it might not be 100 perfect
because we had to do the review in such
a speedy time and there was lots of
things to look at we looked and when we
looked at more things we other uncovered
other things as well so i think this
report is an excellent report it's a
good example of co-parish between
members and officers
um we looked at things that were
relevant to our area and regarding the
bike and review um
it certainly was a high level report we
didn't think it was particularly
relevant
so
so that was the one of the reasons why
we didn't do it and we also had the
benefit of wdc officers who'd been a bit
further down the self build process than
us at times
particularly around charging so i think
what we got in this report was a rounded
one it was considered one it might not
be 100 perfect but i think it's tackling
bridging the gap that we've bridging the
knowledge gap that we've had to
work with the planning so um i think
this report is excellent so i do commend
it to to the meeting
thank you councillor crump councillor
harvey
thank you
um can i just be clear about the process
of what's going on here
um this is a a report and we are being
asked to receive it no more we're not
approving policy we're not doing
anything of that sort i'm conscious that
the contribution
earlier given um about the marketing
period
was
essentially look at the
evidence and the evidence will should
determine whether it's 6 9 12 24
whatever
so we're not making a decision in that
sense about about that marketing uh
period uh i just want to be clear that
that's the case and and finally i know
councillor pempton wants to shut me up
um
can i just point out in my usual fashion
on page 47 the third leg of the
recommendation there is a word missing
which and i only raise it because it is
the recommendation not the content
the word holder should appear after
portfolio
thank you
[Applause]
thank you leader um having been asked by
a colleague to
deal with two
sites one is at alderminster and one is
at
um
indicate because her brother is dealing
with these sites
council feeling are you raising
uh issues of policy in general i am
raising issues on the policy so what i'm
basically
pointing it out is i've seen it in play
i have a meeting with the portfolio
holder and the chair of one of the
parishes to discuss the problems
associated with back land development
where there's an existing
development
and the land behind that is going to be
developed and that is a problem that
we've got to look out for can i be clear
how does this fit with custom and self
build
because
because of the fact that with regards to
matters to do with sewer drainage etc
these have got to be taken into account
when
proceeding i don't know whether i'm out
of here
okay thanks council of fielding
councillor pemberton do you want to sum
up
you thank you chair um
just to again just to to confirm what
we're being asked to do first of all
we've been asked to
note the work that's been undertaken by
the task and finish group
we've been asked to
support the recommendations and then
for
the place and economy portfolio holder
myself to take those recommendations
into account uh in developing emerging
policy
and specifically
asking
me as the portfolio holder to consider
the creation of a two-part register
to address uh the issue that's been
raised in relation to
marketing periods
i said right at the head of this item
that it is for us as decision makers
to have an evidence-based policy that
meets our particular needs
and in specific relation to marketing
periods there are a range of marketing
periods adopted by
different authorities
it is my view
that
a marketing period um does need to be
evidence-based and we do need to have
certainty that if we
stick on a particular marketing period
particularly if we are
at the upper end of the range of what is
usually acceptable and deemed
appropriate
that we should be able to if needed be
to stand that up in an appeal and i can
give members of cabinets the assurance
that any policy position that we come to
whether that be relating to marketing
periods
the nature and shape of the register our
approach to
properties
which should absolutely be the exception
that fall out of
being custom and self-built and going
onto the open market are dealt with
appropriately
and are dealt with in a way that should
a developer as is their rights seek to
challenge the decision of
the decision-makers in the planning
committee that we can stand that
decision up in so far as we're possibly
able to do
so it does
invite me to to look at this to work
with officers to work up a policy that
will go to be finalized to go out as far
as the consultation is concerned i am
minded
uh that
the
current marketing period
uh does not meet
the current needs in this particular
part of the world
what other authorities may decide to do
is clearly a matter for them and is of
course founded on their own market and
residents needs
we are not obliged to all take exactly
the same approach and government is
absolutely clear that our duty as local
planning authorities and policy makers
is to give life to the desire to provide
access to
custom and self-build opportunities but
in a way that it meets
the needs of
our own residents and those people who
desire to have a customer or self-built
property within this planning authority
district
so i am comfortable with the
recommendations and would be seeking the
support that allows the noting of the
report
asking me to take into account
those recommendations in considering the
emerging policy and to specifically
consider the question of the two-part
register
and i would be comfortable in seeking a
second for that councilor parry
i would be very pleased to second uh
this report thank you thank you council
the kettle were you aiming to second the
report or did you want to uh
comment
it was just a comment mr chairman i'm
sorry
um
there is no
in the early part of the report they
talk about
above and below 50
uh house units in terms of time scale
um
is uh
i'm just surprised there is no
reference to a maximum size of a
self-built site
could you
talk to me through that darren not
really helpful
thank you councillor kettle put simply
there is no there is nothing within the
legislation um that could
could ma uh limit the size of a
self-built self or custom build
uh site
um
from one to five hundred in it in real
terms i i'm not aware of anything and
and mr keffer doesn't appear to be
nodding furiously at me to tell me i'm
wrong
but that seems to be as i understand it
there is no upper limit provided for in
the legislation and he seems to be
nodding his ascent so that's the longer
the short of the answer and i see the
chair of the tuscan finish group also
nodding in some agreement which of
course is quite a rarity between
councillor rock and myself
can i just be clear then
so after the after
this has been considered here
when you've actually done the work
council of pemberton
does anything come back here to say this
is now the policy
john do you want to walk through the
process
um thank you well you've got uh the next
item on the agenda is the
site allocations plan itself
a draft and that has
a policy on sus um custom self build in
it
it mirrors what's in this report
um so obviously if we make any changes
we need to
move them in the next item
um
that is a preferred option stage that
needs to go through due process so
you'll see iterations of it as the
allocations plan moves forward
um you know it is for consultation so in
that sense the policy is is draft
the
how you might see
further information on custom self-build
is in respect to the register
um as council pensions alluded to
we will probably need to return to
cabinet with um authorization to set a
charge uh to to do that so you'll you'll
see that again in in due course
thank you mr care for the council of
pemberton yeah so just again for clarity
as the site allocations plan which has
the task and finish
uh sorry
the self build and custom policy within
it once that returns from its next
iteration through public consultation
it'll be at that stage having taken the
public consultation into account that we
then come to a landing on uh a policy
statement that will then put before an
examiner in public
so there is a so we've we've got to get
out with something to consult on take
the results on that bring that back
through and then come to a to an agreed
final version that we are we would be
then putting uh because the site
allocation plan does have to go to its
own examination uh before it can be
adopted as part of the core
strategy hi thank you councillor
pemberton
council harvey uh on
i know this is getting us ahead into the
next paper but based upon what mr
carefort has said if you turn to page 61
of 203 pages of the
site education plan you will see it says
the length of the marketing period is
identified as being 24 months however
this could be reviewed over time based
on experience and circumstances that
i read that to say that the policy
proposed is set
at 24 months and that seems to conflict
with what council of president earlier
said that
whatever policy we come to will be is to
be considered and will be decided based
upon evidence
that seems not to square with a
statement of as being 24 months in a
document we are now we will be asked to
approve as a basis for consultation
that seems to me a stake has already
been put in the ground which is
debatable based on the evidence of the
contribution we had earlier in the
discussion
thank you councillor harvey um
the evidence base is informed and
supported by the consultation
all of the stakeholders will have the
opportunity to respond to the
consultation and and cancel harvard is
absolutely right a stake in the ground
has to be set uh you have you've got to
start somewhere
and um the uh the the task and finish
group um we're minded that 24 months was
the stake in the grand
i think we all accept that nine months
would put us at
the bottom end of the ex
well not the bottom end but towards the
bottom end of the range
24 months may well be at the other end
of the range the advice as i understand
it to the task and finish group is it's
still in the range so we've got to start
somewhere i think would be the answer we
consult on it and i am minded to
look at that evidence base once that
consultation is complete um what it does
as an interim start to do is to provide
some
further clarity for decision makers as
planning applications come through
because i am my i do i am aware that
as as as the speaker indicated there are
at least two
uh where uh the developer is seeking a
determination by the planning inspector
thank you councillor pemberton
and the reality is because this will go
up for consultation depending on the
responses you get
that may be reviewed
good
okay
so
uh
what do we have to
[Music]
right members of cabinet can we endorse
the recommendations on page 47
great
thank you
now to the heavyweight item on the
agenda the site allocations plan
preferred options and once again it is
council of pemberton
thank you chair um the purpose of the
report coming forward to you and what
we're being asked to do as a committee
is to
is to take the next stage the next
iteration of the site allocations plan
out for public consultation um moving on
from the previous version uh published
in october 2020
so so the recommendation is that we we
we proceed to the next round of public
consultation
and that within that as portfolio holder
enlightening in conjunction with
officers uh i am more authorized to make
further minor and editorial amendments
to the regulation 18 um
consultation version and what i'd like
to do just right
at the top of this item is for mr
careful just to give us a quick overview
of why we have a site allocations plan
it's placed within the course strategy
um what it is intended to do what it is
not intended to do just so we frame our
understanding around everything i do
understand there's a speaker
for this item
um yes uh and i'm real uh
should that would you whether that's
before or after mr care but don't rely
can i see clarification from mr carefort
on
a particular issue
before i bring in councillor richards
i'm looking at page 92 mr curford
and it's fairly clear there
from what he said
that the site allocations plan
is covering a short-term period
until the south warwickshire local plan
is adopted
and this comment is made about three
times on this page is that absolutely
correct so the south warwicks are local
completely
well that's certainly the intention
uh jem to do that and we we see this as
a stop gap measure um we are have an
ambitious timetable for the southwestern
local plan um so yes this could have
quite a short
shelf life and can it be clear that once
the south warwickshire local plan is
adopted the site allocations plan in
effect falls away
well there's always a caveat it depends
on what it depends on what the southwest
local plan is is saying but the the
intention sitting here now is that the
the key aspects uh if like in the sap
are carried forward into the southwest
local plan so they're encapsulated in in
that new plan so that yes it could well
fall away we may choose
to want to
hold on to aspects or in the south um
site allocations plan but that's the
choice we need to make in in due course
but the the sitting here now the idea is
that the southwesterly local plan
would supersede the both the core
strategy and the and the cyanocatching
plan
okay
thank you mr
careford council richards
thank you chairman members of cabinet
before you today is the current draft
version of the site allocations plan for
stratfor district council and in your
report you have a series of options
available to you
i'm here to ask you to move option two
that is to request a change to the
revised preferred option site allocation
is planned prior to its public
consultation
the change i would like you to make is
to remove reference to site hemp a that
is east of centerfield street in hampton
lucy
as you all know many of our communities
have undertaken work to produce
neighborhood development plans for their
parish and hampton lucy are among them
their ndp is currently at regulation 14
consultation stage the final stage prior
to
formal submission to this authority
within that plan are a series of
identified sites 11 in all
and a full independent assessment of
each of those sites has been undertaken
east of snitfield street was among those
assessed and the conclusion of that
assessment was that it has limited
development potential i've provided you
each with a copy of that assessment so
you can see for yourselves the issues
that have been raised by the independent
assessor but to summarize they include
topography issues due to the undulating
and steep sloping land
access issues uh in particular from
schnitzelfield street where the road is
relatively narrow speeds are high and
visibility displays are limited again in
large part due to the topography issues
impact on the heritage assets of
riverkeeper's cottage and charcoal mill
the site is in the open country side and
it is also outside of the built-up area
boundary as identified in the site
allocations plan so page
5157 sorry 157 of the site allocations
plan
the site is not supported by residents
of hampton lucy the sheer volume of
emails messages and phone calls i've had
over the last week reinforces that
within the site allocations plan bullet
point
1.3.8 on page 11 tells us that it is
expected that submission versions of the
site allocations plan will be amended to
reflect the changing status of ndps and
at an advanced stage it is clear that
hampton luther's ndp is at an advanced
stage being pre-submission
prior to uh sorry being a final
consultation um uh prior to its final
submission
and that this site has been assessed and
found to have limited development
potential and so has not been identified
for housing development within the ndp
given the weight of evidence against
this site being included in the site
allocations plan you have an opportunity
to remove it now and i would encourage
you to do so prior to the public
consultation and allow the ndp to be
submitted to this council it will
certainly mean that you would not have
to revisit this at a future date once
the ndp has been made um a final point i
would leave you with is the question
that uh council jefferson has asked um
clearly the site allocations plan
is likely to fall away once the south
warrior local plan has been put in place
but as we know this will feed into the
southwest local plan so by including it
now there is a reasonably high chance
that it will continue to be included in
the southwestern local plan so this is a
good opportunity now to remove that
given what we know
is coming down the track with the ndp
thank you
and yes i read
the information that you
circulated uh mr carefood
and i suspect that this is a full taste
of what may come when this goes out to
consultation
so perhaps you would like to pick up now
uh where we are on this and what the
next steps are
thank you may just respond to council
richards point
um
so para 1.3.7 on page nine
um it does set out how we've defined
what an advanced ndp is
and we've taken the view that rate 14
isn't advanced
so that's why
we're comfortable with inclusion that
site
in the draft
as it is now
as council pemberton said earlier
obviously there will be another
iteration of this allocations plan we
will review the consultation responses
and as the ndp progresses it may well be
that the site comes out at the stage and
this is not a this is a conundrum we've
dealt with before with tyso comes to
mind where sites are in because it's
simply one timing because the stage
they're at in their preparation and the
stage the site locations plan is that in
its preparation but as the two move
forward uh one would hope that they they
come to alignment
so i think the picture i'm getting
mr carefort is
that
that site could be reviewed
as the neighborhood development plan
moves further through the process yes it
certainly could be and based on the uh
consultation responses we receive uh to
the uh to the plan as well
councilman richards do you want to come
back on that point if i may thank you
and um and thank you john for pointing
out 1.3.7 i have read that but i'm not
clear exactly at which point um a
neighborhood development plan is deemed
to be at an advanced stage clearly reg
14 and i don't think it refers to rogue
14 in that document but clearly reg 14
is pre-submission stage the final point
before we get to submission
do we need to have the ndp submitted
or about to be submitted where are we at
so i can inform the the residents yes so
it's so essentially it's this council
making the decision to submit the plan
that's
uh which i think is ranked 16 or
freaking 19.
16. um thank you matt um so that's the
point we think is um at an advanced
stage and reason we say that is at that
point the plan is uh relatively fixed in
its content every 14 stage yes it is say
pre-submission but there's still a lot
of ability to flex its content so
yeah it's it's the next stage
thank you thank you mr careford uh i
think
i think that was a discussion worth
having because i think it probably
clarified things for a lot of people
and i would not be surprised if we don't
get more issues like that as we go
through the process councilor pemberton
do you want to interject at this point
do you wish to continue mr carefort uh
thank you i'll keep you brief members
but just to um remind you that uh yes we
have been here before um
with the the
allocations plan what we're trying to do
is is get a
a plan that
can be supported
by members by the communities and one
that is likely to be found sound at
examination so what we have done is is
to tweak the approach and you've got the
the revised approach set out in front of
you that's what we're seeking to
consult on um we've set out a set of
changes and the structure of the plan is
as was um the the key
rationale for
the site allocation plan is to to pick
up on a number of aspects that weren't
included in the course strategy so that
includes
customer self-build um but it also
includes the need for reserve housing
science
and there's a slightly different
approach
uh there uh just to remind you members
of four reasons for having reserved
housing sites so it's to to maintain
five-year housing land supply
to meet the uh the needs relating to
growth at jacob and land rover and
gayton
to to meet the needs from coventry and
whiteshare and then to meet the needs
from elsewhere which is is birmingham in
orbit name so they're the reasons we're
looking to
bring forward the site locations plan
of those four reasons we think that the
birmingham one is the the live issue and
we set out an approach for dealing with
that in in this plan as well but it's in
essence just consulting on a revised
draft that hopefully we can um support
and
move forward
thank you would i be writing also
thinking
mr gerford the site allocation plan
also includes
the wells born campus
the porter brook rail innovation center
and the gateway
german yes you're correct it's got some
specific site proposals in it and
those three are all included in there as
well as well as a a new um an approach
to employment enabling so we're trying
to use the the sap to be proactive and
encourage that economic development we
want to see in the district and give it
um in policy uh position as well um i
want to just say that
um
the the site locations plan it is if you
like a tier two plan
so it sits below the the core strategy
it's set it's it's framed by the core
strategy so it's very much
delivering and implementing on the
strategy set out in the course strategy
we're not revising that dispersal
approach and i understand that
uh why some community communities may
have concerns about that but it's very
much um continuing that approach set out
in the core strategy it will be for the
the new plan the south or actually local
plan to
re-establish what a new strategy for
southwarkshire the district should be
but that's not the purpose of these site
allocations plan this is very much
a part two
for the core strategy and picking up
those specific aspects that the course
strategy itself didn't deal with
and that's why i said earlier it
will have a kind of short shelf life in
that respect
thank you
councillor pemberton then councillor
parry
councillor parry
thank you leader i just wanted to
commend the policy team for the
and the portfolio holder for the
excellent work and in particular what
what i was pleased i am pleased to see
is that great attention has been paid to
look at the density
of recommended
um
number of dwellings for the sites that
they have taken particularly to consider
the local character of villages and they
have
so the the the number of dwellings per
hectare has come down and this is
going to be very much welcome we know we
need a lot of housing but at least the
housing that is being proposed or the
sites
they're being limited so that the
density reflects the neighboring
character of the villages around and i
think that should be welcomed and and um
i'd just like to pay particular thanks
on that particular point and thank you
for your hard work so i've now got
councillor shenton councillor harvey
and councillor barker
sorry
councilman shenton thank you very much
and just a couple of quickies um
the
on page 75
of the
sap
we
and i'm looking at
74 we're looking at 4.1.16
and the build of area boundaries
i noticed it this little coat there and
it also has a map
a room
obviously further on on page hundred and
something
um worldcoat has a a neighborhood a made
neighborhood development plan that was
made in 2018
so i i i think
that's probably just a minor amendment
as far as i'm aware but i'm
i'm i'm looking to john
for confirmation of that and the other
the other thing i'm interested in
is
when we look at policy sap 4 on page 37
and the
the needs of the greater birmingham and
black country housing market
if you look at 2.4.5
we're saying that
the bottom that
based on a calculation and the
calculation could be anything
that we that
we could we want really
that we could
just choose
to go for 132 homes
but we're releasing us sites there
totaling
380 homes
why do we need to release all those
sites i suppose at this stage
um
you might guess that i i'm
the smallest type of those is the one
that i tend to think will cause
a fair bit of
concern due to the plantation trees that
are there but they are plantation trees
so we just head that one up but we're
releasing 300 380
sites for 380 homes and there's only 132
in that calculation at the bottom
do we really need to you should release
all of those so there's two things the
will coat one may just be my
understanding but
i'm grateful for your
comments
thank you councillor um so
my colleagues just informed me that yes
you're right they do have a made
neighbor plan but they haven't uh
identified a built-up area boundary
within it so that's why
uh we've put the boundary
uh insight allocations plan i think
that's right
currently
um which is not unusual um it's their
their choice um but that that's that's
the the difference there um i want to
point out that uh members there is an
addendum sheet sheets
where there are a couple of
parishes
who have got built up area boundaries in
their ndps and they should come off the
list that's
on the reference you gave councillor
in respect of the the the birmingham
issue
uh yes yeah if we if we take a um
that sort of pro writer percentage
approach then the number would be
much less um
yeah we there is a shortfall housing
that exists now
um it's um you know we're coming coming
to the run-up to 2031. um i think
we should be proactive the the short
full figure has gone up overall for the
housing market area i think the risk is
is that if we're not proactive
that you then get into planning by
appeal because you're in a much weaker
position to say well we've we've done
more than our sort of fair share if you
like and we are working practically to
address the problem if you always do the
bare minimum
you're in a it's much harder to defend
that position as an appeal situation the
other reason um and you might say it's a
a slightly practical one is that if you
look at the sites we're looking to
release the the figure is if not the the
sum total of those sites
and now our approach in this version the
plan is to release those uh sites in
stratford and even and mapping green
stratfor even being chosen as the most
sustainable location in this district
and certainly relevant to birmingham so
if we were to reduce that number
we would have to arbitrarily
take off one of those sites
and then you get into a debate well
which side you lose so we thought all
things considered
it was appropriate to say right it's
those sites in totality that we want to
offer up to address the the housing
crisis and the housing need that's
rising from birmingham
council harvey
thank you mr chairman i've got to go to
a parish council meeting tonight
and i can predict a question which could
arise can i change it to page 58
and on page 58 in the colored in block
it
is stated that
uh
self-built and custom-built housing
applications proposals
that are in certain
locations will be supported
uh the first one being within built-up
area boundaries
um did auntie darted out i can perfectly
understand that that's fine
it then goes on to say where there are
available sites adjacent to built up
area boundaries and i'm particularly
concerned with
local service villages
because that would suggest that
subject to them not being in the green
belt
sites
adjacent to
a built-up area boundary
is will be supported
and yet
in paragraph
3.1.1 below
it says however the government does not
expect local authorities to provide such
opportunities on flights on plots or
sites that would otherwise not be
acceptable for other forms of housing
development
and a proposal to build outside a
built-up area boundary
would in my on my understanding would in
principle
would be
not favored
and yet
uh
such a such a
proposal
could be opposed simply because it's in
the open countryside so my question
really is
when is
an area
adjacent to
a built-up area
boundary
inside the countryside or outside the
countryside because
it strikes me that this is something of
a loophole
where does the countryside begin and end
one has to say that our time is mr
cathode when one does have a certain
degree of sympathy for the amount of
forensic scrutiny this is getting
especially quite a philosophical
question um
the i think the distinction is your um
sites on the edge of villages and towns
that are outside the built-up area
boundary they are certainly within what
we define in our plans as the rural area
or uh young countryside
they're not as we would argue in the
open countryside and
it's that word open so
that is it's not defined it is a matter
of judgment and it will vary on a
case-by-case basis but what the
government is trying to prevent and what
we're trying to protect is the
um the development is of if like
standalone isolated homes and
developments in in that sort of wider
rural area so
you know sites that are you know um
divorced from any any sort of form of
settlement that's that's the open
countryside that's what we're trying to
prevent those sites from coming forward
what we are saying is that sites
adjacent to our local service villages
uh because those the sites where you
might get
as we've had a case
in austria for example
they're suitable for affordable housing
so if they're suitable for affordable
housing and we've deemed them suitable
why can't they be suitable for customer
self build so it's the distinction
between sites
well related to this existing
village
on the edge of that village versus sites
that are divorced from the settlement in
the wider countryside can i comment on
that just to come back on that
uh i have a i have a site in mind which
you know in
in newbold
where
um
it is outside the proposed built-up area
boundary and yet it is owned by
a developer who has already got a plan
to build 31 i think it's 31 houses on
that
site outside
the built-up area boundary which is not
now defined as a reserve
site within the end the proposed ndp
am i to tell my residents that
if this developer and i'll use
pejorative language if this developer
dresses up his application as either
custom or self build
that we will support it because it's
adjacent to a built up area boundary
in a limited service village
i think we've got to be very careful not
to consider
individual cases just in case but i
think there is a clear point of
principle and interest here
that probably needs to be born in mind
well just say we're looking to establish
the policy framework
uh where
certain schemes may be supported now
they always comes back to site specifics
but yes you've got a what we're trying
to do is find
uh those sites
uh that could come forward through that
framework to deliver on customer self
bills so
that could be an eventuality
thank you but my residents will thank
you
councillor barker then councillor kettle
some of my residents demand that john
actually comes every time one of these
comes up but we've managed to head that
off so far
i'm just back on page 16. it's not to do
with any wear in particular
but
wastewater treatment works capacity
assessment i'm delighted that we look at
the
treatment capacity
but we're not looking at the sewers
i know that we take advice from
seven trent etc
but
i find that what we're getting from them
is actually woeful
and that somehow we need to be able to
work out that
work backwards if we've done that kind
of assessment for water treatment works
whether we've actually got the capacity
to get into it
um and yes i mean that is personal to
ships because we get covered in pill all
the time but
so the other half of ships is not being
so philosophical
but i want something done about sewers
and i don't know how we can lever that
in
because of the undertakings made by
seven trend
sometimes water whoever the suppliers
are
but they don't seem fit for purpose
i i don't have a definitive arms other
than say i
i understand the issues and it's the
same with infrastructure providers
across the board
i take some comfort from the
leveling up and regeneration bill that
does seek to address this point and make
infrastructure providers
more accountable for the the advice
they're given and a more proactive
approach
um i think that the key thing is just my
officers to carry on liaising with
stakeholders we're doing it far more
regularly than we used to
and to to make the point that yes okay
you've thought about
the treatment works have you thought
about
the pipes as well and it's something
that we're going back to for example the
power suppliers because we're not
satisfied with the advice we're getting
there so
i i think it's yeah i i can't think of
an immediate solution up and we have to
keep
keep talking yeah
thank you mr careful councillor kettle
i'm just going to go back i think
i was going to go back to cancer
howard's point
on on page 73 where we actually define
um
paragraph 4.14
where
distinguishing between land inside the
settlement where new development is
acceptable in principle for man land
outside the settlement where admittedly
subject to certain exemptions developers
generally not accept settlement
and settlement boundaries therefore
should prevent encroachment into the
countryside
so i think
rather sort of um a historical quotation
rhetorical question what is countryside
that seems to say to me that if it's
outside the boab it is
in the countryside and therefore i think
we need to be very careful
in
relaxing those boundaries because it
happens to be on the edge of a
settlement because actually it drives
the coaching horses straight through
having a buab because there will always
be an opportunity for somebody to find
an exception
whereby however remote the settlement
may be from say stratford or southern or
the main road center
if it is out if it is adjacent to
then it's okay but actually that's
contrary to 4.14
um
so i i think we really need to have
better clarity
on what is
and what is not within the boundary of
acceptability
um and i don't think about council
harvest case
um
so i can't you know i'm not bringing
that up
but
if we are going to protect rural
settlements from incremental development
going outside
then um we have to have that definition
i think councillor kettle that both you
and councillor harvey have raised
quite an interesting and challenging
point
councillor pemberton do you wish to
respond yeah specifically on that point
i'm afraid fellow cabinet members i'm
going to disappoint you in the same way
that are disappointed overview and
scrutiny where members of overscoot
overview and scrutiny also ask for the
same clarity about how you can control
custom and self-build on the edge of
settlements and frankly the advice is
that the
the overarching legislation doesn't
allow for that
so we are nailing jelly to a wall here
we are not going to get the kind of
clarity that anybody seeks i am
disappointed about that as our decision
makers up and down the country um open
countryside as i understand it that
there is a there is a separation between
the development and the edge of the
boundary um there is no specific
definition that says
if if it hits this
you get it if it doesn't hit that you
don't
there is a direction of travel by the
government to encourage custom and
self-build and the regulations have been
written loosely enough to give
as much
um
as much latitude in that area as they
possibly can
and that does provide decision makers
and that does provide individual ward
members
with challenges when trying to explain
that to their communities
but i've yet to see anything that would
give regrettably counsellors kettle and
harvey
the kind of certainty and clarity that
you're seeking unless mr cathedral has
got a new smoking gun i'm not aware of
mr carefort new smoking gun please
it well can i just draw members
attention to the uh the last uh sentence
of so this is uh sorry policy
uh sap six
it's page 58 of my printed copy
uh so it's the policy itself part two
so part two two as it were at the very
bottom the the on the end of the policy
um so this is yeah on suitable sites
outside the built up area boundaries
uh etc uh unless it is to meet a local
need identified by the community
so
and i apologize should have been clearer
earlier it's that point so we are saying
these are sites
uh possibly for self build you know not
possibly for self build but meeting
that locally um identified need that
policy approach is consistent with the
core strategy my colleague paul's just
giving the reference
in
cs15 part g where we allow
local needs schemes on
greenfield countryside sites outside
the built up area boundary so we are
being entirely consistent with our
approach because of that local
connection hook i take the point that if
they were for
general
needs then that would be a different
issue but these are uh we're allowing uh
local sites sorry sites to meet local
needs to come forward in these
circumstances so
if you just take the example there of 31
that is probably unlikely to fall within
that
definition
but i don't know five it might be if
there was a local need for five so
that's that's the uh the control
mechanism for this policy and hopefully
that gives you the comfort the other
point of course is this is still the
consultation it'll be useful to see
the views of uh public and stakeholders
on it and communities although um
say that the thrust of this was as was
uh last time as well thank you
councillor shenton did you want to come
back
and then councillor junior and then i
think we wrap this up thank you chair um
i'm grateful to to john for pointing out
the fact that wilmcote haven't got
a defined value i thought all mdps had
got defined built up area boundaries and
having had a look at it
it definitely hasn't so i'm grateful for
that on
another point of clarification though
on page 41 of
the the documents
document we talk about core strategy
policy cs2 requires new development to
include measures that mitigate and adapt
to the effects or the impacts of climate
change
and then on page 61 when we look at
policy
sap seven coming back to and i've only
picked on
the custom and self-built because i just
happened to see as i was
wandering through
we say there that uh d achieving a
minimum 31 reduction in carbon emissions
my question is
one problem because i'm just ignorant of
this but is there a is there a
a benchmark
that we
benchmark that 31
against
or is it
just an arbitrary number
as i say i think it's probably more of a
more ignorance of my part but
um thank you
uh so it's it's neither arbitrary nor a
benchmark as such um
it's
as i understand it's related to what the
um the building rigs are moving to so
it's the equivalence of that that's as i
understand it
but it's not a benchmark target and i
see i think dave barber is on the call
whether
he's got it he's touching his fingertips
but that's my understanding on that one
will be requiring of new developments so
it's in line with that which is a 30
percent reduction or the future home
standard um which is related to the next
thank you mr barber
uh
councillor junior then councillor kettle
then we draw this to a close um yes
could i pick up on page 59 that
the reference to hybrid schemes that are
in the in the box
um it says hybrid schemes incorporating
self-building custom build plots
together with dwellings to meet other
forms of local housing need that
accorded district council policy are
acceptable in principle
could this cover um uh local uh house
small rural housing associations that
want to build
a particular kind of housing to meet
housing need affordable housing need in
a particular community
for example maybe
low low carbon but affordable housing in
a community could that be clarified
secondly uh just a request given that
this is a 207 page document with maps
most of us don't want to print that out
i'm fine i've got it on an ipad would it
be an idea to have one copy in the
members room
for those members that are coming in
that want to particularly check a map um
when they're in uh it might be helpful
um that sometimes maps are a bit
difficult to see but it's the hybrid
scheme i particularly want to ask
about um and then i've got a follow-up
question if i might
okay mr careful that's your answer yes
fine
follow-up counsel the follow-up question
is
given that we are now longer
not merging with the the housing
strategy um will that uh will there be a
revised housing strategy feeding into
the next stage of the local plan um
and will that look at particular
communities and i am thinking i would
like to have some feedback er
a chance to be able to feed into that if
i might
i think councillor barker is not in so
the answer to that is yes councillor
kettle the last point before we wind
this up
um
mr careful you you'll be aware of a
concern a resident was raised not
nothing with my ward
um but what opportunity is there
in this document
to um
further tighten the development
particularly of agricultural holdings
um into var a circuitrious route
uh that uses
building agricultural buildings then
converting them into properties
uh is there anything we can do in this
document to try and tighten
and tighten up that uh what which kind
of council described as a apparently a
loophole
i i would say no because we'd have to i
think revisit uh probably as10 to do
that
um
i think given where we are with this
document it is something that doesn't
fit very well um it's certainly
something we can look at in the new plan
there are other things we want to look
at in the new plan as well that i know
it's frustrating that aren't in this in
in the sap um but i i think we need to
keep it focused and deal with the issues
it's dealing with and perhaps not
introduce
these issues now
i i think it's one we will look at in
indie course but i think you'll try to
know
before i bring uh council of pemberton
pemberton in to sum up
and
propose the recommendations on page 89
i think
sorry
as amended
sorry
i i have to say i think the uh
questions that have been asked and the
level of scrutiny is a
good indication
of how carefully people will be looking
at this site allocations plan
uh
with that council of pemberton
thank you close scrutiny is both a
blessing and a curse
really just to sum up um this is a
document to go out to consultation
just to frame cabinet and wider members
understanding
um and to pick up the point about
birmingham
uh and should we just do the minimum
part of the reason we've got a site
allocations plan which required us to
have 20 reserve housing starts was
because when we gave life to this core
strategy it was off the back of a period
in the sort of early 2000s where we
thought it was a really smart idea to
have a complete housing moratorium so
the client the the then how uh examiner
in public said
i don't trust your ability to deliver on
these numbers because you've under shot
in the past which is partly why we've
got a 20 number anyway so
absolutely with birmingham as a moving
feast and it is
we need to have another and i've had
quite close discussions with
uh mr carefort um it is a tricky balance
we are trying to bring nine authorities
together who could potentially
contribute to birmingham but contribute
we must
um
so the site allocations plan is
absolutely a creature of the core
strategy and what we need to understand
is this is an interim piece of work and
we will have a new local plan
in place as soon as we possibly can to
pick up councillor richard's point
for the avoidance of doubt for any of
those developers listening out there
don't just think that this is going to
be a lift and shift exercise where every
site that's been in the core strategy
and every site that gets put forward in
the in the allocations plan and every
site that gets put forward in the call
for sites is just going to be rubber
stamped through because we're going to
take the same approach as we've done in
the past
those prospects are slim to vanishing
because the core strategy is a good
document it is a sound document and its
sadness depends on delivering the site
allocations plan but our approach the
new local plant will be looking forward
to the middle of the century it'll be
infrastructure employment green blue
environment it'll be housing not just
one of those so the new plan will be
very very different and we'll have
different criteria-based approaches for
all of our communities um with that
whilst i know there'll be lots of
difficult conversations to be had during
the
consultation period and this is a piece
of work that i would commend that we
accept the recommendations and as
amended with your
uh paper there i i propose the
recommendations can i have a second to
please
councillor shenton uh all those in
further members of cabinet
ray thank you members of cabinet so
moving on
uh
this time it's councillor shenton review
of the climate change panel
i don't think they still thank you chair
i don't think this is going to provoke
anywhere near as long a conversation um
as the last item
um
essentially there are
four or five points i'll make on this
one is that the aim is to reduce the
number of meetings that we hold on this
from 12
to six
you might ask why well because
as the paper points out there is a short
period of time
in between each of the months when
effectively we
write the minutes for the one meeting
and effectively then create the agenda
for the next that
to me doesn't seem
an efficient use of officers time so i'd
like to reduce that to six sessions
the other part of that is that the q and
a sessions that we run
every three months would then be three
uh time at least three times in a year
but part of that meeting and then in the
entering months
we want to hold informal meetings
with
warwick district council
to
discuss other issues climate change
issues
that won't involve officers other than
the director for climate change dave
barber it will be totally informal um
and
that the point i will make about that is
that in
uh 1.7
on page
100 no 101.
uh it talks about
in this
as far as this particular meeting goes
with wdc talks about portfolio holder
and two or three others that's now being
agreed at two
so that's that is a deficit not two or
three is definitely two
and
we have run this through the climate
change panel
and i'm grateful to the
deputy chief executive for
helping the conversations
uh on that
uh and then other than uh that
i
really uh just ask you to approve
um the recommendations that we that we
reduce the the number of steer and the
number of uh meetings
with the caveat that the warwick meeting
is
portfolio holder and two
rather than two or three thank you
thank you councillor shenton
uh councillor junaid
i don't think it's the frequency that
matters but what um one car one thing
that was raised was um that the emphasis
on addressing climate change should not
uh come as a result of any reduction
i don't think that's the aim but uh just
that's the caveat
thank you councillor junior
councillor harvey can i be assured that
uh reducing 12
climate change panel meetings to six
climate change panel meetings
plus six steering groups meetings is
actually
involves
less officer work and time
is that really the case
yes
it's simple is the simple answer because
six we would have six meetings which
should be led uh we with officers taking
notes and creating agendas etc and six
meetings with wdc where that wouldn't be
the case it would be informal notes
created by the people at the meeting by
the chair or one of the others in the
meeting so it should reduce the the
number of hours that officers are
spending writing reports on our behalf
it certainly isn't going to dilute
the the aims of the climate change panel
um or of the the stratfor district
council's ambitions
so yes is the short answer on that
uh unfortunately council ascent mr
buckland now has a question
so councillor you you referred to
paragraph 1.7 where it's been agreed
that there'll be two further members on
on the climate change steering group i'm
assuming therefore that carries forward
to page 105 where we'll be asked to
consider the terms of reference appendix
ii the second bullet point under
membership says
two or three
other members if we change that to two
further members from each council
thank you yes please
yes exactly
before we decide on the recommendations
mr barber do you have any comments
thank you so in other words uh
councillor schenten you propose we
accept the recommendations on page 99
can i have a second to please councillor
pemberton are we all in agreement
members of cabinet
agreed good thank you
so moving swiftly on
uh
unblock items
sorry issues arising from overview and
scrutiny
any
council trump
now
but sorry i started to go apologize mr
chairman um yeah the committee was happy
to receive a presentation from helen
peters the chief exec of shakespeare's
england
and we were happy to hear the progress
the organisation was making
and certainly the recovery of tourism
within the district
um which hadn't fallen as much as we had
previously anticipated
um we also
had a fine presentation from cancer
jennings and you can give me that five
pound later council agendas because for
saying that uh to do with the tourism
and leisure uh and again um
a really good debate about that and then
we spoke about the creation of a tuscan
finnish group on the termination of the
merger and instructed officers to put
together a scoping document and the
terms of reference for the group
and this will eventually be agreed by
myself and the vice chair of aoc is sat
to my left
so yeah a really good meeting
and hopefully that covers all the points
that we we talked about
thank you councillor crump much
appreciated
uh there's an amended
cabinet work programme been circulated
so you've all got that and councilor
harvey you had a
comment you needed to make on uh some of
the next items item nine just very
briefly on on page one one six uh
councillor junit has already made the
point
of that so just because the number of
meetings is being reduced does not
necessarily imply anything about the
importance of the item in fact i would
have thought that it is far better
that there are fewer meetings which are
high quality meetings well supported
well documented that deal with
really meaty issues where there are
outcomes
is is better than simply having meetings
for the sake of having meetings that's
all i wanted to say
great
uh
under item 11 start times of meetings
are we comfortable continuing with 3 30
i see no descent so the start timer
meetings will be 3 30.
uh urgent business i have not been
notified of any items of urgent business
so i therefore declare the meeting
closed
thank you
don't break them
you